earlier this week I interviewed David
Wallace wells about the climate and the
the sort of urgent nature of what is
taking place currently and the seemingly
intractable situation that were up
against with when it comes to protecting
the environment and protecting humanity
from humanity effectively and the effect
that we are having on the climate and on
the planet via industrialization and
pollution and burning of fossil fuels
for today's classic interview we're
going to go back to my interview with
David Keith from a couple of years ago
where we spoke about geoengineering we
didn't speak about geoengineering in the
conspiratorial sense we spoke about it
in the sense of as a climate change
mitigating mechanism let's check out
that interview right now I'm joined
today by David Keith who is professor of
engineering and of public policy at
Harvard University you've worked in the
fields of climate science energy
technology you've been in public policy
it's so interesting now what we are
seeing with regard to it I think that
geoengineering is sort of crossing a lot
of these areas that you've worked in and
it's touching on a lot of different
aspects that are increasingly present
sort of in the national narrative let's
start for people who don't know what
we're talking about what's
geoengineering so the idea of solar
geoengineering is the idea that humanity
might deliberately make the earth a
little bit more reflective by some
technological means like putting some
kind of aerosol a fine dust into the
stratosphere perhaps and that that would
partially and imperfectly and in
permanently offset some of the risks the
climate risks that come from the
accumulation of carbon dioxide of the
atmosphere and is this just in terms of
preventing temperature increases or are
there other potential benefits certainly
not just temperature climate changes a
whole host of things from changes in
extreme temperature changes in rainfall
patterns changes in sea level changes in
the impacts on the natural environment
on species and ecosystems and the
evidence which certainly comes with lots
of uncertainty but the evidence is that
a moderate amount of solar to measuring
something that say cut the overall rate
of climate change or warming if you like
in half would reduce changes both the
temperature but also reduce changes
increases in precipitation perhaps
increase reducing the increase in
extreme storms that are the things
pretty clearly destructive to the
poorest people in the world specifically
how would this be done in other words
what would be the sort of technological
mechanisms that would be used to carry
out such a policy so in some ways that's
the easiest part the hard questions are
mostly all about governance and science
well we'll get to that I think it's yeah
exactly but and it's reasonably clear
that at least in this lawn method
putting aerosols in the stratosphere
that really existing technology
essentially existing aircraft
technologies could be used to put say
you know some amount that will wrap up
from zero gradually to maybe over sort
of 25 or 50 years to something like a
million tons a year of material going
into the stratosphere and that that
could be done really with off-the-shelf
aircraft technology that many nations
could access and could be supplied by
many vendors so kind of variants of the
technology that you see in a business
jet nothing all that fancy so the basic
ability again my girl says try sphere is
something that can be done in Causton
aren't very different from the cost of
shipping materials by arif rate across
the Pacific one of the criticisms that
I've read of this type of geoengineering
is that although it might be effective
in terms of the mitigation of climate
change that there are all sorts of other
negative potential environmental
repercussions depending on what
specifically is used as an aerosol have
the developments accelerated in terms of
solving that issue over the last several
years versus maybe in the early 90s when
there were earlier discussions of this
technology
I think the big perspective here is that
because of concerns some I think very
well found illegitimate and some may be
a little bit kind of at the gut level
because of concerns about this
technology there isn't a large organized
research program so for example although
the United States is often seen as a
place of sort of technological optimism
justifiably so whether though there's a
huge overall budget for climate research
of several billion the year not counting
all the money that we spend it we should
spend much more in my opinion on cutting
emissions
there has been no organized US
government research on any kind consoler
dream of sharing and very little
globally there's small research programs
now and in Europe and China and some in
the US I helped to run one but they're
funded dominantly by philanthropic money
these stars is because there's been very
very little government money so that the
important answer at this point is that
we don't know very much there's there's
plenty and I can tell you someone we do
know but to be clear the argument that I
and I think many people like me are
making is not that we ought to do Gino
missionary I think that would be
ridiculous the argument is that we ought
to have a serious coordinated open
access research program to understand
more about how well would work what the
risks are out and controlling on the
internet if you were to for example
prepare with an intern for an interview
with someone like you and research
geoengineering you would inevitably come
across all sorts of conspiracy theories
about geoengineering sometimes the term
climate engineering is used you will
then probably go down the internet
rabbit hole into chemtrails and I've
interviewed one or two of the the
chemtrails conspiracy theories how did
this start
that geoengineering became so tied into
some of the I guess I would call them
not as not making a value judgment but
merely from the way that that the
material is presented some of the
juiciest conspiracy theories on the
Internet how did this develop I don't
know is the short answer I think from
what I understand there were long held
beliefs by probably a very tiny number
of people that the u.s. government was
deliberately manipulating the ionosphere
through something called the HARP
program which was actually a pretty
normal nerdy physics program to try and
beam microwaves into the ionosphere and
and a bunch of related programs that
people who kind of want to see some
nefarious coordinated action imagined
were happening and then as the more
public discussion of solar juma sharing
began to be more visible say a decade
ago those two ideas were somehow
conflated I don't know why what I think
is clear is that the extraordinary
spread of social media has really
changed the way these things work so
that there's much more you know it's
much easier to produce fake news as
we've seen in in lots of countries
including the US the last few years it's
much easier to produce materials that
appear too naive viewers to be
convincing and so you can get many more
people falling into the trap of
believing stuff that you know
objectively to the mainstream seems
really bizarre and and extraordinarily
unlikely to be true to it and that's
true on all sorts of cases but this is
certainly a particularly odd one and it
stirs up a pretty high level of hatred
and anger in the Internet and I think it
probably will affect the kind of normal
discussion of jima sharing which itself
is controversial but in totally
different ways let's talk now a little
bit about the sort of politics and
governance issues around this I mean
certainly I think we can all imagine how
if you go up into the sky and you start
spraying aerosols or whatever it is
ultimately used those aerosols are not
going to respect to these imaginary
lines on maps called country borders so
logistically who needs to agree to such
a program what are the sort of
governance obstacles that that would be
presented
that's a very hard question it's it's a
it's an emerging question I mean for all
of these global public goods and I think
that's ultimately what this is if it
makes any sense
including goods that of course like any
of them have some risks and side effects
the way we manage them is in emerging
isn't it was a work in progress so
that's true from managing pollution of
the ozone layer it's true for match in
global climate it's true for for
managing infectious diseases and all
sorts of things so there isn't a simple
formula for what's legitimate obviously
international organizations matter but
soda coalition's of individual countries
and I think it will be some mixture of
what some individual countries do what
environmental groups or other
transnational public organizations do
and and what the international relations
like the United Nations do so it's
really hard to guess what I think is
really hopeful is there are now serious
emerging efforts to look at what it how
that governance would work so for
example a guy called Janos pasture who
is the lead advisor to the
secretary-general for climate is now
running an effort to try and develop
governance for solar generation area one
of the concerns that I have that I know
is shared by at least some people in my
audience with regard to whatever we may
ultimately decide to do to try to deal
with human caused climate change is that
rather than taking a development like
geoengineering or a new form of energy
whatever the case may be and saying okay
now we can use this to actually make a
net improvement to what we're doing to
the climate that it will be seen at
least by some as sort of carte blanche
to keep doing exactly what we're doing
right saying hey now instead of just
improving the situation we'll keep doing
what we're doing but we won't be doing
as much damage because we've come up
with this new thing how do we deal with
that well I mean I think that is the the
central fear that it beyond any other
has held back researching this top
and and I think there's ways in which
it's both deeply legitimate and and some
ways that it's less so so yeah of course
there will be some interests interest
for example in parts of the fossil fuel
industry they would like to keep the
party going and not reduce the fossil
fuel consumption the hard truth is that
if you want to stable climate you have
to bring fossil fuel consumption to zero
eventually and nothing about solar do
you measure any changes that you must
bring emissions to zero in a net solar
generation can reduce the risks of
climate change for co2 it's already in
the air but it can't eliminate them and
so I think it's certainly true that some
forces allied with say the fossil fuel
industry that doesn't want to see
hundred regulation might use the
possibility of solar Jewish sharing as
an excuse for inaction but the question
is how powerful those forces really be
in the end the political forces that
want to see our climate protected need
to win anyway and I think gradually we
we are beginning to win we are beginning
to win the battle to restrict co2
emissions and I don't think that adding
something that further reduces perhaps
significantly reduces the risks to the
most vulnerable in the planet which is
what solar generation could do I don't
think that in the long game that
suddenly means that we lose the
political ability to cut emissions but I
agree it's a legitimate and hard
question all right something we will be
dealing with certainly for years to come
we've been speaking with David Keith
professor of engineering and of public
policy at Harvard University thanks so
much for talking to us about this thanks
a lot it's great to be on your show